hey guys I just want to talk for a bit
about planet Zoo which is a new game
that was just announced by frontier and
it's something that I've sort of been
looking forward to for a really long
time but nobody really knew if it was
gonna happen or not there have been
rumors about a new Zoo game coming out
by frontier for a few years now ever
since the trademark was registered by
frontier for planet Safari there's been
a lot of speculation about this kind of
game coming out and today it's been
confirmed which is super awesome
so yesterday I got some early access to
some press release about this game so
that's why I've been able to get footage
and some screenshots slightly ahead of
everyone else so I just want to take a
bit of time to talk about these give my
opinion and also do a bit of speculation
about what I think this game is going to
be like and I'll mostly be focusing on
the screenshot because for me at least
this is definitely the most interesting
thing because it is a direct reflection
of what this game is going to be like I
have to say that the reveal trailer is
absolutely amazing but at this point it
just kind of feels like frontier flexing
on us how their animation departments
and art departments has done a great job
on this video but you know it doesn't
say anything too specific about the game
I did talk for a bit with Rudy Ren kamel
exchanging ideas and what we found in
these pictures and videos and he did
bring up that he watched this video and
compared it to the planets Kosar review
which was almost four years ago which I
also talked about back then to see what
things were very similar in these videos
and I do think that you'll be able to
find the different animals and different
themes that they show in the video in
the game as well I can't imagine them
showing off bears in this video for
instance and not ending them as a part
of the game but when it comes to the
graphics and you know what it generally
looks like of course it's not
representative so I'd rather want to
focus on the screenshots instead and
honestly this game as a whole which I
think
has the potential to be a really good
zoo game there hasn't been a very
well-known or popular zoo game of this
sort I think ever since ooh Tycoon which
is game that I played back when I was
younger but I haven't returned to this
genre much definitely not as much as the
roller coaster games so personally I'm
not much of an expert on zoos either
even though I like to visit them every
now and then in real life I haven't been
in the zoo gaming genre recently
although that said Frontier has been
very active in this genre they've made
kinectimals they've made Zoo Tycoon for
the Xbox they've made rollercoaster
tycoon 3 which I mean if you want to
look at it in a broad perspective that
is kind of a zoo game that was the first
roller coaster tycoon game to add actual
animals and zoo mechanics into the game
and if in Jurassic world evolution which
is about dinosaurs but really it's a zoo
game at its core with dinosaurs as a
skin although my biggest hope for planet
zoo is that it's really going to be most
similar to planet coaster
even though planet coaster is a theme
park game and planet Zoo is a zoo game
I think these games are super similar
and planets who seems to borrow a lot
from planet coaster and I think most of
this becomes really clear in the
screenshots which honestly at first
sight I think looks really good there
are obviously some slight graphical
improvements over planet coaster it
looks slightly different I think for me
it seems like there's a more rustic tone
to the images overall the lighting is
less harsh the shadows are a bit softer
the general you if the image is a bit
warmer as well I think planet coaster is
very bright and bluish colors and to me
this definitely seems a bit more warm in
terms of colors but it's clear to see
that a lot has carried over from Planet
coaster if you zoom in on some of these
palm trees for instance I can easily
recognize that some of these have been
directly imported from Planet coaster
and to what extent they have updated the
graphics on things like this
is really hard to tell I think they've
probably updated quite a few things make
things more high-resolution or things
like that everything just seems like
it's been touched up a little and
they've tried to learn from what
happened with planet coaster so for
instance it really looks to me like
there are more terrain textures and
while it looks like it uses the same
engine for the Train as well so we get
the same voxel terrain as we had in
planet coaster there seems to be more
textures together than we had in planet
coaster some splotch of red ish mud like
rock texture here between it and there's
all kinds of different textures
scattered throughout this whole
enclosure of the elephants and maybe
this is just really well made and hides
the fact that we don't per se need to
get more terrain textures than planet
coaster I do think that it looks a lot
better in this department then planet
coaster does I think there are also a
lot of new trees which look better than
the trees in planet coaster ever did
especially these two big trees that I
honestly don't know any names of are
just ever so slightly more detailed and
more realistic than the trees that we
had in planet coaster so lots of really
nice slight improvements that you know
even though the game looks very similar
it's a planet coaster these improvements
are going to definitely set it apart I
think there are also some very positive
aspects to the game being similar I
found that in the press release the the
developers stated that you can unleash
your creativity with the next evolution
of the planet coasters tools so I expect
that we're going to see the same
piece-by-piece building tools that we
had in planet coaster maybe even the 3d
maneuver gear that's been used to place
objects in all kinds of ways I could
definitely tell from the rocks that's
been placed every now and then you could
see that these rocks are all placed in
slightly different positions so I think
we'll have the same kind of control over
how we play certain things which is
absolutely awesome I still really like
the building system of planet coaster
and it's amazing to see
this game actually have that especially
after Jurassic world evolution was much
more limited in terms of scenery I also
think it's very exciting for the reason
that I any planet coaster player can
probably jump into this game and already
be familiar with the basic building
mechanics and just have to familiarize
themselves with how the animals work and
try to get used to the new gameplay
elements but all of the design elements
the creative aspects of the game look
very similar to planet coaster and how I
think it's really important also to
stress that this game really seems to
put a very similar focus on creativity
as planet coaster which I'm super happy
about first of all I was glad that this
is the game that was being announced
because even though a lot of people were
expecting this sooo game you know when
Frontier announced that they were going
to announce a new game I really wasn't
sure if it was even going to be this
rumor so I was really hoping that it
would be the zoo rumor so I'm glad that
turned out to be true but I'm also
really glad that they are focusing on
creativity as much as on management or
at least it really seems to be that way
so far because I do like the balance
between that as opposed to focusing just
on managing the park now speaking of the
animals I don't think there's too much
to speculate about them yet we can only
see them from a distance so it's hard to
tell how good the models are going to be
for the animals but they definitely seem
like they're going to be quite dynamic
we already see some different poses here
there's a baby elephant sneaking from
some food here and in general I think
from Jurassic world evolution we can
tell that the modeling inference here is
just absolutely great
so that should probably be fine there is
there are some wolves here is what Rudi
was speculating and I think they are
probably wolves so we don't get to see
too many animals here but I think that
we'll probably eventually see all of the
all of the different animals from the
reveal trailer pop up in the game as
well and according to the press release
these animals are going to have a big
focus on how they behave
so actually managing the health and
happiness and all of those micro
management statistics of the animals is
probably going to be part of the game I
think we can already see here that they
do actually get some play things in all
of these soccer balls and you have to
feed them and what according to Rudy are
probably going to be sprinklers and I'm
really not sure we just have these small
buttons throughout the the enclosures
and if these aren't sprinklers I have no
idea what else I think it was a good
idea that they are probably sprinklers
but we'll see what kind of effect that
has on the biomes for instance how we
have to care for maybe not just the
animals but the vegetation or otherwise
the scenery of the enclosures there's
also an interesting a bamboo stick or
some kind of scenery element like that
between the rocks and it'll be
interesting to see if the animals will
have any ways to interact with different
scenery items in their enclosures but
you know we all just have to wait what's
gonna happen with that well I do think
is really cool about the animal behavior
is that we see a small baby elephants
here in the water with some animations
around it as well so they are probably
going to play with different elements of
the environments now something that
struck me especially is the way that
these enclosures have been closed off
from the paths and I was really worried
when I was looking at this first that
we'd be very restricted with what kind
of fences we would need to put around
enclosures because for me personally a
lot of the the best zoos managed to
bring you really close to the animals
without ever you know actually making it
dangerous for either the animals or the
guests and you just need a lot of very
good strategies for hiding the different
mechanisms that you have to protect the
enclosures and using these these slow
ramps down into a lake is something that
works really well for a lot of real life
sewers and it seems like they've done
very something very similar here because
there is the lake over here
but there's no actual fence on this side
of the path where the lake is already
protecting the enclosure and I don't
know if it's simply a fence that is
hidden underneath the terrain something
very similar seems to be going on
underneath all of this terrain but in
any case I think it's good to see that
we are probably going to be quite
flexible and how we fence off the
enclosures we see the same over here
where we have a glass wall which to be
honest is kind of pointless in this case
I would probably want to have some kind
of path behind this and make the glass
the only way to see the enclosure and
there's an elevated pathway here anyway
but yeah despite how pointless it looks
in this park I think it does show off
that there will be some kind of
flexibility in what fences you use to
fence off the enclosures same goes for
this area here there's a stone fence
here and then it changes to what seems
like more a steel railing fence and
there's also that classic path from
planet coaster that we don't recognize
from when we were struggling with
terraforming here this looks like a very
steep staircase not sure what's up with
that
also what Rudy mentioned which I
completely missed and it's very easy to
miss because it's all the way in the
upper left corner of the picture but
there seems to be a trek over here and
really also found that in the concept
art there is a railroad track in here
and I originally didn't want to look at
the concept are too much because it
isn't exactly representation of what the
game is going to look like but there's
probably going to be a train in the game
so there is probably also going to be
some kind of track building mechanic
related to that which is really cool
it's it's nice to see that even though
this is a zoo game there is still some
kind of ride and I'm very curious to see
what that is going to be like other than
that's there's just a lot of scenery I
think it's a point now it's in this
build there are some walls here on the
side which seem to be really be a piece
by piece built especially because we can
tell that there is a classic planet
coaster
here with a rounded curb on the side and
then the walls are actually built on top
of that and the same happens in the
distance where we have some classical
looking buildings with Palace trades and
lots of items that I've never actually
seen in planet coaster so definitely new
items but at the same time it really
clearly looks like the same building
tools have been used as in planet
coaster a very similar piece-by-piece
building mechanic and the same also goes
for this building in the background
which Rudy was also thinking might have
windows that don't exactly align like
the windows have been placed piece by
piece as well I'm not entirely sure if
that is the case but definitely it
probably is it looks like it's been
built by a similar builder as planet
coaster so yeah altogether I'm honestly
very cautiously happy about how this
looks so far looks very promising
especially because it seems to take the
elements that work best in planet
coaster brought it into a new game and
added some improvements to graphics and
models and the art style while at the
same time I hope learning from some of
the mistakes or things that were left
behind at first in planet coaster and
including them right away from the start
of the game to incorporate those a bit
better I remember for instance
transparency was an issue in Planet
ghost for a long time so it took a long
time before a glass made its way into
the game but it looks like we are gonna
have glass pieces at the very least
glass walls right from the start in this
game so overall I think it's very
promising especially because it's
related to planet coaster and I think as
a final notes and this is something that
Rudy also brought up so I really can't
thank him enough for the bit of a
brainstorming session that we had about
this but what I think is finally also
worth pointing out is the fact that it
still uses this very similar title and
logo to planet coaster so it's obviously
its spin-off of sorts and maybe not even
a spin-off really an additional entry in
a very similar series of games
and the question is just if it's gonna
stop here or if we're gonna see more
planets games because at this point you
can pretty much add any word at the end
of Planet and turn it into a whole new
management games and there is definitely
a slew of different types of management
games that I would love to see tackled
in this sense so I think that's
interesting it's not so much about
planet to itself but I think it's worth
thinking about and well depending on
what the reactions on frontier side are
to the speculation we can probably make
up whether this is likely to happen or
not but I really hope that we're going
to see maybe some planets water parks or
what about Planet skiing or things like
that in any case and yeah I'm gonna say
in any case I'm happy that the rumors
about the super game from frontier turn
out to be true but I'm very curious to
see what you guys think about this
whether you think it looks good and
whether you're looking forward to Izu
game again which I think has been
lacking in the PC markets for quite a
while so it'll be interesting to see if
this game will make a similar splash -
how planet coaster did when especially
compared to the zoo games the planet
coaster game also made quite the splash
in the genre because there has been
quite a lack of good theme park games
for a few years before that as well
anyway that's been it for today so I
hope to see you guys in the next planet
coaster video and until planet sue comes
out maybe we won't see too much of this
yet but once this game does come out
I'll definitely make some videos in this
as well
so stay tuned for that bye guys